ten-nine
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening and welcome to the
wonderful world of chemistry a magic
show my name is Neil a hasari I'm from
Australia that's why I sound funny and
tonight it's my pleasure to be with you
to host you as we take you through an
educational journey in chemistry which
will include many demonstrations let me
start by saying at the outset the people
who are doing these demonstrations are
trained experts you should not try any
of these demonstrations at home it will
be hazardous to your health so the
question becomes who are these people
who are going to do the demonstrations
for you this evening if I'm going to
introduce my team I need some music
so we have from Florida a person who
loves her pet bunny Emily boss we have
from Massachusetts a person who is the
greatest cornhole player in the world
David Charbonneau we have from Ohio
a person who on his birthday wants to
sit by himself and read a book from
cover to cover Nicholas Smith we have a
Yale undergraduate a senior who likes to
wear his younger sisters clothes vivec
Suri
from New Jersey we have a person who
loves colors she loves to talk Julia
Curley from North Carolina we have Yale
undergraduate vivec Jack MacArthur and
finally we have another person from
Florida a person whose pet cat loves to
play with Emily's pet bunny matthew
espinosa and you see ladies and
gentlemen you don't know any of these
people none of these people are famous
and part of the reason they are not
famous is because chemists and
scientists in society are not famous but
I can tell you that if these people were
basketballers in a few years time they
would be like LeBron James or Diana
Taurasi if these people were movie stars
they would be Leonardo DiCaprio and
Hathaway if they were musicians they
would be ed Sheeran or Katy Perry but
because we don't value science in the
same way as entertainers they will work
in a very quiet way to make your life
and the person in the Beck's life and my
life better for the next thirty years of
their lives so
so we've introduced the team before we
start with any demonstrations this event
is about chemistry and we need to
introduce chemistry to you and the
question becomes what is chemistry
chemistry investigates the composition
properties and behavior of matter so of
all of those words the one you might be
unfamiliar with is matter what is matter
matter is anything that occupies space
and has weight so look around this room
pretty much everything you can think of
fulfills that description vivexx hat
this bit of tape the seat you're sitting
on so chemistry involves understanding
everything that around us and this
matter is made from objects which are
known as atoms how should you think
about atoms well we have approximately a
hundred and twenty different types of
atoms which are represented by the
periodic table and atoms are like
letters in Words we can combine atoms to
make molecules just like we can combine
letters to make words and all of the
different elements have different
properties and they have different
properties because they have a different
number of what are known as protons
neutrons and electrons to do our first
demonstration of the evening which
involves understanding the properties of
different atoms please welcome Matthew
Espinosa
hi everyone
so as Neely said all elements are unique
and so this leads to them all having
different properties since they have
different properties we can use those
differences to distinguish one element
from another so one example of this is
when you heat up in an element to very
high temperatures they give off
different colors and so you've actually
seen this if you've been out on July 4th
and you've seen fireworks going off all
those bright red colors green colors
that you see coming off of the fireworks
are due to the extreme heat and the
colors are coming off of those elements
which are heated and getting excited so
for today's demonstration what we're
gonna do is heat up a bunch of different
elements to high temperatures and show
off those colors so as a bonus if you
remember some of the colors for the
elements you might win a prize in Nick's
demonstration which is coming up so
Neela can you play the appropriate
background music for me thank you
so this first element is copper does
anyone want to guess what color it is
copper gives off a green color next is
sodium any guesses yellows a great guess
does anyone know what you do to a dead
chemist
you bury them and that's the next
element next is potassium any guesses
[Applause]
[Music]
so potassium gave us a purple color
Nexus strontium any guesses
[Applause]
lastly we have lithium any guesses
[Applause]
thank you everyone now to challenge you
did you pay attention during that
demonstration we're going to have a
competition nick is going to burn
something for you and you're going to
have to tell us what is the element
that's being burnt all right so as Neil
I just said it's quiz time here at Yale
all right so I've got here two syringes
full of liquid and I'm just going to add
them here to this solid and I'm gonna
step away for a moment here and in just
a moment you'll see the two very highly
reactive chemicals that I just combined
catch on fire and they'll provide a nice
color for you and you can guess then
what element is providing the flame ah
there goes it's just starting off
all right so if you think you know what
it is just shout it out Neal a do you
want to be the judge of this somewhere
someone over there said the right
element the right element is potassium
Mitch you can give them their prize we
have one very congratulations
congratulations congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we've described to you what
chemistry is the next question might be
why should you care about chemistry well
the simple reason you should care about
chemistry is chemistry has made some of
the most profound contributions to your
quality of life things that chemistry
impacts includes pharmaceuticals solar
panels toys like my favorite the rubber
ducky paints cosmetics plastics the
person up the back who's currently
looking at everything on their iPhone
chemistry was part of the reason we can
have iPhones because of computer chips
but I know we have some young people in
this audience and young people they
don't like hearing from old fogies like
me instead they want to get their
information from people who are the
stars of social media so I added up who
is the person in the world with the most
followers on Twitter Instagram Facebook
snapchat and all these other things
they've never heard of and who has the
most followers
Zuckerberg anyone anyone have any other
thoughts Bill Gates
okay well I will tell you the answer and
I will show you that that person in fact
loves chemistry that person is your
favorite and my favorite Taylor Swift
and so to show you that Taylor Swift
loves chemistry let's look at this video
clip of Taylor Swift look at what Taylor
Swift is wearing Taylor Swift is wearing
the periodic table look at that you
might say this was one freak video and
that Taylor Swift was trying to be a
nerd so she pretended that she liked
chemistry so I'm going to show you more
evidence that Taylor Swift loves
chemistry Emily
she's again pining about her lost love
interest and she's doing chemistry look
at her she's in the lab doing chemistry
she's not doing it safely she's not
wearing gloves and things go wrong so
what I have given you is two compelling
reasons why chemistry is important it's
everywhere and Taylor Swift loves
chemistry now I said earlier that we use
the atoms to make molecules just like we
use letters to make words what can we
make by combining atoms we can make a
very topical molecule which is bad for
our environment like carbon dioxide by
combining two oxygens and one carbon we
can make water by combining two
hydrogen's and one oxygen we can make
methane which you'll see later on
tonight by combining four hydrogen's and
one carbon just like we have simple
words we have more complicated words if
we combine more letters we can do the
same with molecules if I combine more
atoms this array of carbon nitrogen
oxygen and hydrogen I can make the
molecule that all your parents need to
get them through the day caffeine if I
am sick I can make a molecule which will
kill bacteria namely penicillin which
has carbon oxygen sulfur nitrogen and
these connections between the atoms are
known as bonds now the different
molecules and indeed the different
elements exist in different phases and
you are familiar with those phases let's
think about water when it's really cold
out
side water exists as a solid in the form
of ice when it's a nice day like in fall
we will get water in the form of a
liquid and when we heat water we get
steam and in fact all molecules and
atoms can exist in these three phases to
do a demonstration that shows us about
molecules and atoms interconverting
between the phases
please welcome jack Vivec and date okay
hello
for this next demonstration we're going
to be mixing we're going to be mixing
two things nitrogen and water now does
anyone know what state nitrogen is
generally found in if you said gas you
are correct approximately 75% of the air
that we breathe is made of nitrogen now
if you cool nitrogen to a really really
low temperature you'll get it to
condense into a liquid as you're about
to see Dave pour now as Neely I
mentioned when it's really cold outside
like it has been in New Haven water
turns into ice which we find in snow and
all over the grounds so when you get
above 32 degrees water turns from solid
water into liquid water now that happens
at 32 degrees does anybody know the
temperature at which water boils when it
turns from a liquid into a gas shout it
out
a hundred degrees Celsius yeah so zero
degrees to freeze and a hundred degrees
Celsius to boil now liquid nitrogen as
we see over here is super super cold and
the temperature where it turns from a
liquid into a gas is really low can I
hear some guesses as to how low the
temperature for liquid nitrogen to boil
is lower negative 200 degrees is how
cold this rate here liquid nitrogen is
and so if we take boiling liquid water
which is at a hundred degrees Celsius
and we add it to this liquid nitrogen at
negative 200 degrees a lot of energy is
going to be transferred really fast and
we're gonna see something very exciting
are you guys ready for that
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay did you like that one it's one of
my favorites
as well now I've put another molecule up
on the board does anyone know what
molecule this is any guesses shout it
out sugar that's right if you like
chocolate if you like candy this
molecule is the active ingredient of
those things we eat and to do a
demonstration involving sugar please
welcome Dave Charbonneau all right thank
you anyway so in my hand I have a
container of cotton candy as Neil I
mentioned cotton candy is primarily
comprised of sugar or sucrose typically
when we see cotton candy we think about
it in the solid state as it's appeared
here in the solid state the sucrose
molecules are surrounded by other
sucrose molecules however what would
happen if we introduce a solid like
sucrose into a liquid such as water it
would melt that's a guess anyone else
it would evaporate there's another one
okay so to begin our investigation I
figured we could watch a short yet
informative video clip of a raccoon who
has been given a piece of cotton candy
so let's see what happens
okay so what happened is the solid
dissolved exactly thank you
so the raccoon didn't have the type of
chemistry knowledge that we're learning
here today it dumped its cotton candy
into the liquid water and then the
cotton candy appeared to just disappear
leaving a very sad and confused raccoon
[Music]
so when the cotton candy goes into the
water as we say dissolves the cotton
candy the sucrose the molecules are
still intact no bonds were broken
however the sucrose molecules are now
just surrounded by water molecules
instead of other sucrose molecules as we
would think of it in the solid state so
different solids can dissolve in
different liquids and only a certain
amount of each solid can go into any
given volume of a liquid so I figured we
could do a quick demonstration to see
just how much cotton candy can dissolve
in water but before we do that Neela do
you happen to like cotton candy Dave I
love cotton candy
that's excellent Neely and a follow-up
question how much cotton candy do you
think will fit into this small volume of
water Oh Dave I think you're smarter
than a raccoon so I think you're going
to be able to do maybe one and a half of
those tubs okay one and a half of these
tubs well you know what Neely since you
like cotton candy so much whatever
doesn't dissolve you can keep yeah that
seems fair
okay let's see how this goes one down
Neela not looking so good
two down
that's easy three down
for
[Music]
five down you it should I give him the
last one
[Applause]
six tubs of cotton candy into this small
volume of water so now let's check back
in with our raccoon friend and see if it
was paying attention to the lecture
[Applause]
so I'm not that heartless and just like
the raccoon we want Neal a to be happy
as well
so I got him his very own tub of cotton
candy
[Applause]
all right thanks Dave I am feeling
generous I think that you right here
would like to have some cotton candy so
here you go but don't put it in water
okay earlier on we define matter and we
said that all matter
hazmats and actually all atoms have mass
and the different atoms have different
masses so potassium has a different mass
to sodium to carbon to hydrogen and as a
consequence all molecules have mass let
me ask you a question what has a larger
mass one feather or one brick a feather
is heavier than a brick
[Applause]
so a brick is heavier than a feather and
the reason a brick is heavier than a
feather is because of a concept called
density and density is mass per unit
volume okay so in the same volume of a
brick it's going to weigh a lot more
than the same volume of a feather
because it's more dense and we are
scientists so I'm going to ask you a
question do gases have density what do
people think okay so I hear some people
say yes and I hear some people say no so
what do we need to do we need to do an
experiment and to do that experiment
please welcome Nick and map
[Applause]
alright Neely well thank you for that
but before we get to the experiment
Neely we wanted to ask you a quick
question what's your favorite Disney
movie Aladdin has to be Aladdin Aladdin
okay who's your favorite character in
that film the genie from the lamp the
genie from the lamp well Matt does that
remind you of anything yeah every time I
think of genie I can always think of one
phrase right when he appears all I can
think of him is saying you can't spare
[Laughter]
anybody living space pepper but that
[Applause]
all right so now that we have done that
little ditty for you all let's explain
what was happening so Matt when he was
made his voice sound really deep what he
did was he had a balloon full of a gas
called sulfur hexafluoride and when you
breathe it in you change
[Music]
so Nick inhaled sf6 which is a very
heavy gas instead in my hand I have
helium so this is what the is the gas
Nick initially inhaled and as you can
see it's lighter than air that's why it
floats when you have a balloon from say
the zoo so when I inhale this and the
reason this is happening is because this
gas is lighter and so it passes through
my vocal cords much faster alright so
just one more bit of evidence if we
haven't convinced you that sulfur
hexafluoride is more dense than helium
we have here one more balloon full of
sulfur hexafluoride and we have a
balloon of helium that I will not let go
because then it will be up at the top of
the ceiling for the next three weeks
alright so thank you
[Applause]
so far in tonight's presentation all we
have done is we have changed molecules
and atoms from one phase to another or
we have inhaled them but we haven't done
my favorite part of chemistry which is
to do chemical reactions so what we do
in a chemical reaction is we can take
say molecule a and molecule B and we can
make two new molecules C and D what is
an example of that was anyone excited
when at the start of this show we
ignited those balloons that was a
chemical reaction and the chemical
reactions that was occurring was that
one molecule of hydrogen h2 was reacting
with half an equivalent of o2 to make
water which is h2o and chemical
reactions as I will describe to you in
subsequent slides are extremely
important in everyday life however not
only are they extremely important they
are also often aesthetically extremely
pleasant to watch Emily is going to do
an unusual chemical reaction for you now
thanks Neela
so one of the things that I think is so
cool about chemistry is just how tiny
atoms and molecules are they're so tiny
I can't believe it but the problem is
that when we want to do a chemical
reaction we're breaking bonds and making
bonds and because they're so tiny we
can't actually see what's going on so we
have to come up with other ways to do
that so one way that we can do that is
by using something called an indicator
an indicator is a compound that changes
color when a certain reaction is
happening or when a specific chemical is
present so in the speaker I
a source of iodine and I'm going to pour
in a solution of starch and starch is an
indicator for iodine so no color change
yet but we're gonna watch this chemical
reaction happen when I add a solution of
hydrogen peroxide just and
so if you watch closely you'll see that
the solution is changing colors and so
the reason that that's happening is
because the amount of iodine that's in
the solution is constantly changing
which we wouldn't be able to know if we
didn't have the indicator and as Neil I
said it's also really nice to look at
[Applause]
one of the areas where chemical
reactions are extremely important is in
energy we all need energy for our daily
lives almost all of you came to this
venue somehow probably you were in a car
and in the car you did a chemical
reaction involving oil to get here some
of you I'm sure like to cook when you're
cooking you do a chemical reaction which
involves natural gas and similarly
sometimes we use coal to generate energy
now all of these energy sources release
carbon dioxide as we'll explain in a
subsequent slide which is bad for our
environment and we would like to use
renewable energy sources such as wind
biofuels or the Sun to use these types
of renewable energy sources
we will also need to do chemical
reactions
now those chemical reactions are often
quite complex so we're going to
illustrate how we get energy from using
fossil fuels which is what we
predominantly do today and the type of
reaction that we predominantly do is a
combustion reaction that's what you saw
at the start of the show when we burnt
those hydrogen balloons another type of
combustion reaction involves taking
methane which is natural gas it's what's
probably lighting your stove and two
molecules of oxygen and you will make
water and also this molecule of co2
which is bad for the environment why do
we get energy from this reaction it's
because the bonds broken contain more
energy so the CH bond in methane or the
o2 bond in
oxygen contains more energy overall than
the bonds made in carbon dioxide and
water and as a result the excess energy
is released as heat we are now going to
do a demonstration which involves
burning methane and later on in this
demonstration I need a volunteer from
the crowd is anyone willing to our be a
volunteer so I'm feeling lazy so I'm not
gonna walk very far you my friend are
probably too young I'm sorry so I'm
gonna choose the person with the blunt
end here and I am going to talk to her
while vivec Emily and Matt start this
demonstration for the rest of you as
Neil a just mentioned for this
demonstration what we're gonna do is
we're gonna burn methane so methane or
natural gas burns at actually a really
hot temperature does anyone want to
guess what temperature it burns at
higher I'm talking about Fahrenheit so
we're thinking high
[Music]
methane burns at 3,600 degrees
Fahrenheit at its hottest temperature
now that's really hot and what we're
gonna do today is collect methane and
bubbles and burn it on our hands that's
kind of crazy I mean this is what you're
cooking with this is used even as a
rocket fuel I don't know about you I
don't want to stick my hand behind a
rocket
that doesn't sound great to me so yeah
I've been thinking about this actually
for a while since last year
unfortunately I got some great
suggestions last year from the audience
one of them was buy fake hands and so I
looked that up on Amazon they're pretty
expensive so instead I thought of a
better idea instead I'll have my good
friend vivec risk his life and burn his
hands instead so here you go Overbeck
this is all you thank you very much but
fortunately I am Not Afraid of how hot
the methane sari is going to be because
I have a plan I'm going to protect my
hands with something really common and
that's water water has this great
quality called the specific heat
capacity and water has a really high
specific heat capacity which means it
can absorb a lot of the heat from the
methane so if I cover my hands in water
before I put the methane and light it on
fire on my hands I will be perfectly
safe
so right now gubeck is just capturing
the bubbles of methane which are coming
off he's dipped his hands in water and
now emily is going to ignite the methane
[Music]
now
[Applause]
guys I thought that was okay but it's
really not as big as some of the
demonstrations that we've done today and
this is why we need a volunteer because
I record it we've got a volunteer and
you can see that we have equipped her in
personal protective equipment so that
she doesn't get hurt she has a lab coat
she has their safety glasses and now
what we're gonna have her do is we're
going to have her dip her hands in this
water to protect ourselves so it's not
bubbling do nothing and vivec is gonna
start dipping his hands in the water and
then you're gonna go and collect some of
these methane bubbles together and so if
we have four sets of hands we should
have many more methane bubbles then when
we just had the vet set of hands by
himself
okay and they're gonna come out in front
of the stage and they're gonna stand
like this so that they're holding their
methane bubbles close to each other and
then we're gonna light them together all
right
so for our client volunteer we have some
chocolate after she has removed her lab
coat and has safety glasses you can't
eat around chemicals of this nature so
we're gonna leave that there we're going
to thank our volunteer and thanks for
that and we're going to talk about other
forms of energy so in this for the
experiment we just did we released
energy in the form of heat but almost
the biggest source of energy that we
have comes in the form of light because
the Sun generates so much energy for
this planet and just like some chemical
reactions release heat some chemical
reactions release light and so Julia is
going to do a chemical reaction which
releases light Thank You Neil a now as
Neil a said at the beginning of the show
I really love colors and so I was very
excited to get to do a demonstration
that shows you some colors today
now I have two flasks up here at the
front one is filled with luminol which
is a chemical that exhibits
chemiluminescence
and now chemiluminescence sounds like a
fancy word but all it really means is
that when it reacts with molecules such
as hydrogen peroxide which is in the
other Flex class that I'm holding it
releases light which is what
luminescence means
so you see when I mix these two things
together they make this beautiful blue
color which as you might guess from my
hair is one of my favorite colors in the
world this property is not just used in
chemical in the chemistry lab it's also
found all the time in nature so
fireflies which you see during the
summer use chemiluminescence to attract
their mates when they light up there are
creatures in the sea that use
chemiluminescence to deter prey from
attacking them and it also happens to be
very pretty
all right let's thank Julia for that
demonstration
now chemical reactions often don't
happen spontaneously we need to do
something to initiate a chemical
reaction what are some examples of this
I am sure that there are people in this
room who love to cook when you cook your
food doesn't do anything quite often
until you put in heat right you light a
flame and then your food is made
similarly you can start a chemical
reaction using light just like reactions
release light sometimes they can be
initiated using light we are going to do
a chemical reaction which we need to
initiate which involves taking
isopropanol a common chemical that you
might even have in your home and oxygen
and making carbon dioxide and water here
is the structure of isopropanol it has
carbon atoms hydrogen atoms and oxygen
atoms and this reaction won't go unless
we give it some energy I could leave
isopropanol sitting in a bottle for
years and nothing would happen until we
give it some energy before we do the
reaction what type of reaction is this
chemical reaction so I want a more
specific answer than a chemical reaction
combustion there we go
you've got it have some chocolate and
now Emily will do this demonstration for
you alright thank you neil a so what
I've just done is I've put some
isopropanol in this bottle and shook it
around a little bit so I wanted to get
lots of vapors of isopropanol into the
bottle so right now there's really no
isopropanol in there just the vapor I'm
just gonna clamp it up here and let's
input some energy
whoa nice so that worked pretty well but
I think we might be able to go bigger
what do you think
can we go bigger all right let's see
what we got here I think that'll work
[Music]
all right so I'm just doing exactly the
same thing shaking it around trying to
get lots of vapors and now I'm going to
pour out the extra I guess if we really
wanted to we could fill the whole thing
with isopropanol but we're not going to
do that and this is a similar process to
what takes place in your car in an
internal combustion engine igniting
vapors and that's what powers your car
so you're all familiar with this process
even if you haven't done it just trying
to make sure I have all the isopropanol
out
all right gonna wipe off the top so I
don't want any on the outside all right
let's give this a try
ready
okay thank you very much Emily so we've
introduced you to different types of
molecules tonight one very important
type of molecule is known as a polymer
and to take to make a polymer we take
one chemical and we repeat it over and
over again and we form connecting bonds
between the repeating unit so we might
take a molecule a and we will convert it
to a strand of a prime many units of a
prime which have a similar structure to
a what are some examples so plastics are
one of the most important examples of
polymers a compound such as polyethylene
which is this carbon and hydrogen
containing molecule can be polymerized
to make a structure that looks like this
and that is in plastic bottles which you
see everywhere polymers are also crucial
in biology DNA which encodes our genetic
information is a polymer and the monomer
units that encode DNA are not a single
molecule but four different molecules
and you combine these four molecules in
lots of different ways and you make
different structures another important
polymer is nylon nylon is in our clothes
you see that you can get long strands of
nylon to show you how easy it is to make
a polymer
please welcome Julia and Dave
thanks very much Neil a-all right
so as Neil II was just saying polymers
are incredibly important in our everyday
life and especially nylon can you get
the camera please Nick so everyone can
see and so what I have here in these two
small flasks are the two different
monomers that make up a nylon polymer
and so I'm going to pour one gently on
top of the other and at the interface of
the two solutions where they mix we're
going to hopefully get a nice polymer to
start forming which you'll all be able
to see so if I just let that mix for a
moment and let our polymer start to form
you see that from these two clear
solutions starts to form a solid which I
can pull out and you see a strand of
nylon so Dave could you give me a hand
here it looks like we're making quite a
bit of stuff all right
and so nylon is really useful as Neal I
said it's used in a lot of clothing it
has some great properties it's really
stretchy but also strong it can be dyed
in a variety of different colors so you
can buy clothes and whatever color you
want and as you can see it's pretty easy
to make Dave I think you can go a little
further I think you can keep going and
so it's pretty easy to make I'm pretty
fun and if we wanted to we could
probably dye this a fun color and we
could all knit us all a nice little
sweater all right well keep going guys
keep going I think you can make it to
the audience notice this thing is not
breaking it's incredibly it's an
incredibly long single strand yes Beck
yes we might do some help we're here we
need some help keep going keep something
at this dance thing all right we're
gonna keep going up the stairs we need
more people we need my rape Buddha
Holies no one in the audience touch the
molecules you need to be wearing gloves
in order to touch the polymer strands
thank you
you just put this in the guy's just
another teaching model teaching moment
we practice this are two days ago and
two days ago we could not get our bit of
nylon past the edge of the taser and we
were very worried it was going to be a
disaster but Julia went into lab and she
practiced for many hours and you can see
how long her string of nylon was now we
said that you could initiate a chemical
reaction using heat or using light
sometimes the amount of heat that you
have to put in to a chemical reaction to
get it to start is simply too great for
us to manage if say we needed a reaction
to go at a thousand degrees Celsius it's
very difficult to control chemistry at
those temperatures so there is another
way that we can do reactions that are
otherwise difficult and this is known as
catalysis
where we add something called a catalyst
to our reaction and a catalyst is a
really incredible molecule because what
a catalyst does is I can put it into a
reaction it will cause a chemical
reaction to occur and then I can get the
catalyst back at the end of the reaction
and we might have a chemical reaction
which involves a plus B going to C or D
and we will get no reaction if we leave
a and B to sit for 500 years if we then
a catalyst to the reaction of a and B in
seconds at room temperature we will make
C and D what's an example of this so two
slides ago I told you that we could
polymerize a molecule called ethylene to
make polyethylene which are plastics if
I have ethylene which is a gas in a tank
nothing will happen to that ethylene if
I add a catalyst
I can make polyethylene in minutes at
room temperature so why are catalyst
important at the start of this
presentation I said here is all of the
things that chemistry can do well it
turns out that 90 percent of consumer
products are made using a catalyst at
some point in their synthesis so without
catalyst all the toys that you know and
love as well as more practical items
would simply be too hard to make to do a
demonstration which highlights catalysis
please welcome Nick and Jax
hi there everybody
so as neil i said we're gonna show you a
demonstration of catalysis now and in
doing so we're gonna answer the question
that everybody in the room has been
thinking about all night how exactly is
it that an elephant brushes their teeth
the answer of course is with elephant
toothpaste and that's what the name of
this demonstration is called now you
might have seen this before because
recently the most recent winner of Miss
the Miss America competition did this
demonstration as her talent so if you
liked this demo you can just refer to me
as mr. Yale 2020 from now on alright but
now on to the serious chemistry so we
have in each of these flasks a mixture
of hydrogen peroxide and a little bit of
dye just for color and hydrogen peroxide
is a very unstable molecule now over
time it will slowly decompose and turn
itself into water and oxygen gas but if
we add a little bit of a catalyst will
make that reaction go much much more
quickly and so that we can see it we've
also added in a little bit of soap to
capture all of the bubbles that will be
created jack is going to help me because
I don't have four hands and on the count
of three Jack okay one two three
and there we have it elephant toothpaste
[Applause]
all right everyone you have been a
wonderful audience tonight
and I would like to say that I hope
today is just an introduction to your
education in chemistry over the course
of the year through the Yale pathways
program there will be many other
activities that you can engage in today
we've shown you the broad range of
chemistry but chemistry combines many
different subfields there's organic
chemistry
which looks at the chemistry of carbon
and hydrogen
there's inorganic chemistry which looks
at the chemistry of all the other
hundred and eighteen elements and then
if tonight's presentation really scared
you
there's theoretical chemistry where you
never need to do any experiments before
we finish tonight I have some concluding
comments and we have one last
demonstration now we titled this the
wonderful world of chemistry a magic
show but the reality is nothing in
chemistry is magic we can explain with
the fundamental principles of science
everything that we did tonight and to me
learning about fundamental properties is
incredibly inspiring because by
understanding fundamental properties we
can make a profound difference to the
way society operates so to finish I'm
going to welcome back the team we're
going to have the lights brought on and
Matt is going to unfurl a banner
and this banner has a message on it
which you may or may not be able to see
but to really reveal the message we're
going to welcome back the team so first
up Emily and then Jax and then Nick and
then Rebecca and then Dave spray away
guys make this message appear
[Applause]
so what we did on this bit of paper was
a chemical reaction to make color and
all of us believe that chem is cool and
that is why we signed our names to this
thank you very much and enjoy your
evening
[Music]